[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
hello
it's it's me mark mcardle and welcome to
black man beyond uh in case you're not
familiar in case you're you're new to
these parts uh once every couple of
years uh and maybe even more frequently
now that we're somewhat quote-unquote
back to normal
kevin will go off on tour
he will have a movie to support and he
will do what few other directors in the
world can do which is hit the road and
sell tickets and go in and talk about
his movie all around the country and so
when he does that when he's off to
the distance far-flung all four corners
of the earth um
we do a little thing called black man
beyond which is just me sometimes it's
me and a guest sometimes it's me and a
guest host and then sometimes like today
it'll just be me and batman if he
decides he wants to pop in and talk
about star wars or lower the rings or
uh house of the dragons or or any of the
other things that we're going to talk
about today but
this is where we are again this is how
it goes so hello
how are you today i feel like i should
mr rogers this [ __ ] like i should get a
cardigan and like change my shoes and
put on a little vest and you know sing a
song welcome welcome to the neighborhood
song
welcome to the avengers campus
um but i don't have a [ __ ] song um
because it's still just monday um and we
have a lot to talk about we have a whole
mess of d23 games i mean that's
ultimately the reason why we're doing
this today is because so much [ __ ]
dropped the d23 ignoring it for too long
felt like a their reluction of duke felt
like it was irresponsible for a for a
co-host of a pop culture podcast to not
cover pop culture so here we are gang uh
how are you i hope you guys are well i
hope you're doing all right if you're on
the west coast i hope you're surviving
the heat if you're on the east coast i
hope you're surviving the killer wasps
um if you're in the middle and we're
surviving the tornadoes
um and the heat and wasps sorry about
that middle people um
but before we go much further we are
going to do the thing that kevin and i
never get to do which is
rapidly blast through an ad
because you know you and i we you know
we love kevin's we really really do but
uh doing an attitude with kevin is a is
an exercise in glory and wonder but not
brevity um
because once we start talking once we
start [ __ ] bouncing it around
suddenly we're doing songs about blue
chew we're doing little skits about blue
chew we're doing a one-eyed play about
boner pills um won't happen today boys
and girls even though the sponsor for
today's episode of black man beyond his
you guessed it blue chew um and so i'm
going to read this ad copy in as a
potentially plumbing way as i can
um i wonder is there is there a voice
that i can do for this
even though i don't do voices very well
and i end up [ __ ] up voices whenever
i try
um i don't know we'll see what happens
it'll start one thing and become another
thing i've often tried scottish and
ended up jamaican um
so we'll just we'll see how it goes
so the temperatures aren't the only
thing that's rising this summer that's
right this episode is sponsored by
bleach
guys confidence can take you far in life
it can also help you in the bedroom
especially when it comes time to step up
to the plate
that's where bluetooth comes in it's a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in chewable tablets they're a
fraction of the cost you can take them
any time day or night you can plan ahead
or be ready when an opportunity arises
or needs to arise
process is simple sign up for
bleaching.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and it's all
online no doctor's office visits no
awkward conversations no waiting in line
at the pharmacy um so hey guys
you can also be excited to see the
postman as excited as your lady is
perhaps because when your package has
arrived your package can arrive i always
say first impressions are important so
what about lasting impressions leave
your lasting impression
on to
bluetooth.com so we've got a special day
for our list go to bluetooth free try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code fatman at checkout just a five
dollar shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code fatman to receive your first
month free
visit bleacher.com for more details and
important safety information that's
right hey listen
bluechew.com
promo code fatman get your first month
free
so
thank you bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast
yay
all right
um
i guess
i i i had some personal news um this
weekend
um actually it was last week it was
friday it was the first day of d23
and uh and and you know how on this
podcast occasionally kevin and i will
talk about things that we're each
working on and we can't mention what
they are
um potentially for years and years to
come um i finally got to talk about one
of them
this past weekend um i was at d23 with
the good folks at sky dance new media
and marvel games to unveil or be part of
the unveiling of a black panther captain
america game that i uh that i did some
writing
um during the pandemic and we'll do some
more writing on in the future um
because there's a lot of
there's a lot that goes into making a
game um i'm not gonna say more than
television but it's a longer process
than television
um but yes it's world war ii it's black
panther it's steve rogers it's azuri
t'challa's grandfather not t'challa
coachella's grandfather it's gabriel
jones where they have a poundland
commandos and uh and a character who has
dropped into comics here and there but
has never really been explored named
nanali who uh who is a wakandan spy
um
and so it's it's a big-ass adventure
game amy henning is the creative
director of this game and if you know
her name at all
um you know the kind of game she does if
you don't know her name but you played
uncharted
then you know the kind of game she does
because she was the the creative
mastermind behind the uncharted games
and so
um this kind of like two fisted pulp
adventure with an ensemble cast in the
middle of it with hydration big threat
and punching nazis all day long like i
don't i don't know how you could find a
reason not to want to play this game um
and we so we dropped a very early sort
of first look teaser for the game which
sets the the place and the time uh
occupied paris um it sets some clues in
motion you know there's a as we follow
inside this this apartment we see sort
of hydra insignia on
um on some documents on some file
folders that were clearly classified and
every should have left wherever they
were
um
and uh
and then you see cap shield
and then you see five claw marks on cab
shield and then you get this badass
reveal of black panther with a little
tiny cape um
yeah it's uh it's it's been a it's been
an adventure learning how to write this
game
um and uh and all of the permutations
thereof and just the process of games is
so vastly different
than the process of writing tv even
though amy very much wanted to put
together a team that felt a bit like a
tv writer's room um so she uh she leaned
on her her trusty writing partner i
found him todd stashwick who has been a
co-host of black and amber under the
past friend of the podcast
um
who then sort of reached out like fury
style um
white nick fury not sam jackson of fury
um to assemble his version of the
avengers and he he reached out to me to
appeal the cooper who you may know as
also having been a cops of this podcast
uh a black man beyond uh who wrote
malignant work on star trek changing
worlds nicole levy who worked on cloak
and dagger
jeff thorne who worked on black panther
comic books in addition to leverage
um
and uh and evan narcisse
who uh who also wrote like in the comic
books and has been working on a bunch of
video games including the miles morales
game um
and uh and and
dr chris bell who is a sort of in-house
um wizard over at
um skydance new media and we all kind of
sat in a room uh on zune for almost a
year um
sort of figuring out what this game was
going to be and what the adventure was
going to look like and one thing that
amy is very insistent on
and it's one of the reasons why i was so
excited about it is that you know i'm a
gamer and have been for a long time
um
you know 2600 was my first console uh
not a fumble brag about my advanced age
but um
games have become something of an
adversarial pursuit right it's like
you we all talk about the problems of
memes is did you beat the game
as opposed to
nobody ever says beating a film that you
watched or a record that you listened to
or a tv show that you banished you don't
beat any other version of entertainment
but you beat a game
because games have you know
sort of leveled up in their level of
difficulty and playing them not just the
games are hard because you know they
are
sure there's levels of difficulty
there's ways to adjust it whatever
but the the legitimate fact of picking
up a hunk of plastic that has at this
point now
one asami buttons on it and trying to
force yourself to
you know learn this whole new way of
interfacing with anything um to to try
and have fun
sure if you're experiencing it you can
do that and have fun doing it i do that
but it's not it's not inviting to
anybody else
and so
amy and the gang it's kind of new media
was very much about like listen if we're
going to play with this idea we're going
to play with marvel which at this point
is the most popular ip intellectual
property in the world we want to have a
game that is inviting is as inviting as
to as many people as should be possible
so
um
part of the the story
problem to crack was how do we make a
game
that will invite not only people to want
to play it who may or may not have ever
played a game before how do we how do we
invent a control control structure that
can can give you this sort of
unparalleled level of of immersion
without having to button mash stuff
um and then how can we make it an
experience a dramatic emotional
experience that somebody would want to
sit next to you and watch you play
as opposed to tell me what happened let
me watch the cutscenes it's it was all
about trying to figure out how to create
that level of immersion and you know
it's from what i've seen in the game
where we're getting you know that was
always the target to try to hit
and if anybody can hit it amy can hit it
um
i cannot say much more about the game
than that um for any number of reasons
um not the least of which is i don't
want to ruin anybody and i don't want to
get in trouble
because i
i've i have occasionally said dumb [ __ ]
and
gotten myself in trouble and i don't
want to do that anymore so
all i will say is um the game is a bit
of a ways away it's still untitled um it
will be a console experience
but
when when they can show more when we can
show more i can't wait for you to see
what uh what they're working on because
it's it's pretty glorious
um
because who hasn't always wanted to
smack around nazis um as a superhero
with a shield or with claws
or with daggers or with sniper rifles
um metaphorical smacking around of
course um
but yeah that was that was the first
thing that i had to do that was anything
related to d23 was friday was going
there and doing press and going sitting
on a panel on live streams and being
interviewed by the ellie times and
and games insider and cnet and folks
like that and it's it it was a roller
coaster but had a good time having a
good time because it's it's
it's easy to have fun promoting a thing
that you think is good um and i think
it's gonna be great
so so yes that was that was my d23 bam
um oh bam bam is here
are you
allowed to say whether or not
it fits into mcu cannon
um or will be considered
it
the way it has been explained to me
uh as how marvel games views their
relationship with marvel with the mcu
is that they don't want
the games they don't want a great idea
to be sacrificed in the temple
of
uh of canon
so like every game kind of takes place
in its own siloed
omniverse multiverse universe whatever
you want to call it
but
we also knew going into this game that
a decent chunk of the people who were
going to play it only really know the
marvel universe from the mcu
and so to directly contradict what they
knew about black panthers and captain
americas
felt like folly
so
while this game is probably not mcu
canon it does not contradict anything
that you know fronts you can
so if anything it sort of illuminates
moments it does kind of
um
uh recontextualize some moments
because in our game
um
t'challa is not the first black panther
steve rogers has met
um
so
so when in civil war infinity war you
know steve rogers is coming into
conflict with with t'challa
there is in our story
a previous black panther two generations
before t'challa that he's also been on
adventures with and so then how does
that how does that little bit of
information shade
his interactions with t'challa um going
forward
so and it's not and it doesn't
contradict it it doesn't run against it
just hopefully amplifies um hopefully
it's filling in a couple of blanks that
the mcu has yet to invest in
um
but yeah yeah man um it's uh it's been
it's been a riot
and it's been a riot
not telling
any more than that
um
but yes friday was a big games day at
d23
but saturday
was the big other things at d23
and we're gonna get to that in just a
second but before we do that before we
get into the trailers and the news drops
and the castings and all of that stuff
um there's some television that i've
been watching and i have to imagine that
uh that your friend my best man
has also spent a little bit of time uh
investigating
namely um lord of the rings rings of
power
and uh house of the dragon
um
hey
i'm back i've seen both
you soon are you up to date on both up
to date on both
um how are you feeling about these shows
i
if i had to pick one to finish and only
one
prior to episode four of game of thrones
i would have picked rings of power
but i very much feel like this past week
they went full thrones with game of
thrones
and i had uh
let me get the spoiler warning up here
uh before
if you have not seen
episodes one two and three of lord of
the rings rings of power and episodes
one through four
of house of the dragon um we may spoil
some stuff i don't think this is going
to be a crazy deep spoiler cast
um
so so i mean you don't have to literally
[ __ ] mute us or anything or go away
for a couple of minutes but we may
mention a thing or two so
tread gently it's um
it is uh
i had a really big
i love rings of power because i think
the pacing
is what it needs to be for lord of the
rings i find myself like re-watching
fellowship of the ring over and over
because
whereas i used to hate the pacing of it
now i kind of love the pacing of it i
like that it
has slowed everything way down um
but my biggest issue and it's such a
insane gripe
did you notice that galadriel
in what must have been reshoots has dark
roots through her hair her fine blonde
elven hair
like they spent a billion dollars on
this season and they couldn't have
gotten like a hairdresser to touch up
her roots every week so
i know it's so silly but that
instantaneously called out to me like
oh she's not an elf she's an actress
which i i mean i know that but it like
is kind of a weird like breaking the
fourth wall thing
um
but overall i really enjoy it i think
it's really
cool
uh knowing a little bit about like
you know pre peter jackson lord of the
rings and how they're hinting at
different things
it was really cool to see
um
like durian and the dwarf
layer when it's
at its height and things like that i'm
in for it but i'm the easy i'm the easy
one to get on that
yeah no i i agree with you if i
if i have to choose between these two
shows and i don't so it's somewhat of a
move
but if i will say this not that i have
to choose which one do i enjoy watching
more than the other
um
it's it's rings of power
um and it's not that that the house of
the dragon is a poorly done show at all
like they have some of the best actors
in the world working in the height of
their powers
um
it's just that there's this sense of
of mysteries revealed and
new mysteries appearing
and even just down to the basic kind of
you know
the the color palette of the show the
places that we go
you know just are somewhat more inviting
to me than being inside these sort of
dank castle corridors
for like three and four and five
episodes in a clip you know like i i do
miss the kind of the the world travel
out you got from game of thrones
is here we are in king's landing here we
are in winterfell here we are in marine
here we are in in dorne here we are and
like
that the feeling of
there were different palettes and
different modes and different characters
and this will be green and this will be
brown and this will be red and this will
be white like even just that experience
of watching it and having that sort of
visual diversity um
i'm not even going to go there
without adversity in fantasy but i think
you know how i feel anyway
um i'm not getting that from house of
the dragon like it feels very much like
if there was a
um
i don't know
an office building in game of thrones
land like this is the same kind of bleak
we're having meetings in the sandy two
or three conference rooms feel to it
um
where i was like yeah no here we are in
the sundering sea and here we are in
in in numenor with you know these crazy
statues not so you know human like
whatever the
the numenoreans and then all i mean it's
the look of that show is just so
inviting to me even when it's supposed
to be bleak even when you're with like
the goblin prisons and your elves being
held and like it's just it feels huge
it feels
it feels huge the way that the original
game of thrones feels
and house of dragon fee it does it feels
tiny
and
the other thing about rings of power
that i
loved uh especially i think after
episode two
was the orcs were scary
it wasn't some like
like stooge cockney like
batman 66 no name no face henchman
it was terrifying like it was a scary
monster
that i thought like well if you're gonna
make a show without
sauron the big eye in the sky like way
to go in making the henchmen scary like
every one of those orcs is a like a mini
monster movie uh that i i love that too
yeah you know and and and there's this
sense
of like
the the full palette of the human
experience and your elf experience and
neuromorph experience which is
all of the durian elrond um whatever
durian's wife's name is all of that
stuff in episode two
is just so like
romantic and like friends who haven't
seen each other a lot you know who have
built some sort of grudge over years and
now they're trying to thaw it and elrond
has a little bit of the manipulator but
durian is the guy who really wants his
friend back but can't swallow his pride
and then the
the the mrs durian who thaws it and it's
like you know the whole like there's a
sapling from the the great tree in in
whatever
city it is all of the names are
beginning to blend into me um
you know
yeah but the treat is in kassadin from
linden
which is the white tree that eventually
will
end up in gondor
or whatever or is that the white tree
that's in newman or ends up in gondor
because
you know ellen dale and his brother
isildur and his brother form and gondor
and that
all of that deep lore but like
the [ __ ] druid is growing in elven
tree in his living room because he has
this love for his friend that he can't
even really talk about
and like all of that stuff was just so
lovely and sweet and like
yes you're then going to get misery and
dread and yes you're then going to get
adventure and all that stuff whereas
house of the dragon
it's really all just misery and dread
um
you know it's it's it's just a lot of
portrait
and as as much as i did yeah there's
there's there's a bit in episode four
that does remind one of the old days of
game of thrones um literally some of the
central tenets of one of the major
relationships of the game of thrones um
i found myself wondering
if you took out that part of those
scenes and again spoilers you guys if
you don't want to hear it i'm not going
to talk about it i mean we are going to
talk about it you don't hear you know
meet your ears
but
if you took incest out of the major
relationship that evolves and progresses
in episode four of house of the dragon
i don't know what
what happened
how that affects either those people
i never thought that i either then
wanted to do that i never thought that
that was where that story was going i
never thought there was some like weird
attraction that had been bubbling there
um and then suddenly just happens and
like these says yes we're supposed to
recoil from that and we do because
yeah get a throne with that
you know and also she's probably any of
the actresses of age but the character's
like 14 or 15 years old maybe
and so that's all
i think i think they cleverly did that i
think this episode takes place like
two years later
from episode three
and they make mention that she's like 15
16 so i think they very cleverly did it
so that she was
not having sex pre-18
if you do the math
yeah because they do like you run your
marriage to her for 18 months
and you cut it short like you know i get
it
um she doesn't look any older
if they did be like here's our now older
actress that would reintroduce him for
in here and now
um that might have been the time to do
it um
but i just it i i understand all of the
chess pieces that are moving
um i get it i get the plot stuff
um but i'm just i'm not yet invested
in any of these characters really um
you know other than i get it women can't
be queens they never have been before
it's it's unheard of and you gotta have
a male heir which that seems to be the
ongoing
um
beat of of house of the dragon
and
like i'm gonna keep watching it because
of course i will
but i am not actively looking forward to
it the way that i'm actively looking
forward to lord of the rings um and i'm
not sure i could have picked that at the
start of both of these shows
i'll uh i'll give you the opposite
viewpoint in that i sat down to watch it
with jen and we sat down to watch house
of dragon she's never seen game of
thrones
and was captivated by house of dragon
for to the point that last night she's
like we watched two episodes back to
back
uh i was like hey do you want to go
watch rings of power
episode three she's like i fell asleep
halfway through the first episode i'm
done
so
yeah i mean there is something to i mean
she likes like
sweet magnolias and what is it virgin
river so she's into that like kind of
like you know game of thrones picks up
where like wwe was like the nighttime
soap opera for men so she's like into
that sort of thing
um
more so than like magic and
and somebody who may or may not be
gandalf crashing on a comet
um
yeah i mean it's
it's funny like i i did not love the
pilot for uh
rings of power
um i just didn't quite engage with it
and i did sort of knock off a little bit
in the middle and then have to kind of
rewatch it
but then as you get into episodes two
and three i was like oh [ __ ] okay i see
what we're doing here all right i see
i see these sort of quest stories and
these characters who have things they
need to prove to each other and here's
and and some of it was like very basic
like here's your your elf when you're
human who are in love and can't speak
their name and then they get ripped
apart and how he's either going to get
back to where tell him he really loves
her and then
galadriel is the sort of soldier who was
supposed to go to you know elf heaven
and i was like okay i want to be on the
hop off of this boat i'm gonna go back
and finish my [ __ ] so she's like the the
the exiled warrior who's gonna do the
thing that nobody else can do and i get
that and
introducing characters like hal brand
who's you know the the king who was
not so hard at being king and you know
then you're like who is here son of a
[ __ ] and ellenville is here and is that
sword and arsenal and you start
connecting the dots between lord of the
rings and rings of power and that's
always fun
like there's just it's more active in my
brain
than house of the dragon is which is
just i guess this girl's getting older
um maybe she's gonna get married um
damon's a bit of a dick but he's fun to
watch and
we build up a crab keeper bad guy for
three episodes and then kind of dispense
with him immediately so i don't even
know the real threat is
um but okay you know it's like oh sure
patty constantly is a fantastic actor i
will watch him do fantastic acting um in
five or six scenes of any given episode
that's great
um
but i don't know
it it doesn't have any inertia for me
yet
do you um
do you think that uh i think my favorite
part is the actress that plays renera i
think she's captivating um
and
when she's on screen i like i want to
see what's going to happen even if she's
just
chit chit-chatting with her her friend
do you think that
the the because i think we get like one
more episode with her and then we switch
to the a new actress for that role
do you think that's gonna be that's
going to
hurt the show you think it's going to
make it feel too disjointed and weird
and
i mean i think i think the time jumps
are not helping this show
you know like i was trying to think of
another show that i've watched that skip
so fast
right at the beginning
and i couldn't think of one like there's
plenty of shows to do time jumps because
that's you know that's that's part of
the the tv toolkit
but it usually happens in in a way it
doesn't happen a lot it usually happens
like once
after you're already invested in the
characters after you're already invested
in their storyline and then it becomes a
twist
like the the time i i always think
immediately is the battlestar galactica
at the end of season two going into
season three
when it's you know baltar is president
and he's president for real and he's
ready to do all the great things for the
people and it's awesome and then you
time jump a year later and baltar is
surrounded by prostitutes and he's drunk
he's operating pills and you know the
colony the new capricorn or whatever it
was is a mess
and then the cylons show up spoilers for
a 20 year old show
the cylons show up in the middle of you
know the worst presidency anybody's ever
seen
um
fictional
and
and uh like that's great like suddenly
it becomes oh [ __ ] what happened in that
intervening time what
how what what's what are the personal
relationships haven't they got married
and they've got a kid
knowing you're gonna kind of uncover all
of that stuff when you come back into
season three
that all works
but like in episode two of the show
you're like we're six months ahead
episode three two years ahead like wait
what
what happened in this time like suddenly
there was a war now the war still going
but it's going badly and now we gotta
stop the war like what
like i love wars give me actual warship
like
that's what game of thrones did so well
was they like here's the building thing
here's how these actions are all having
you know these toppling effects and
if you jump too much time you lose all
of that temperature it just becomes and
here we are now and here's who we are
now
um
and so i i don't know like it's
it's it's
it just it distances me from the drama
of these characters
and
not that you couldn't do it though like
if you did it well like i want to say
that that the foundation books as
asimov's books like do massive leaps
through time
you know and uh
but it's finding a way to make those
leaps work for you finding a way for
like everything to be moving forward
um for for
collapse
to be rapidly encroaching
but it doesn't feel like it's a virtue
yet in the storytelling it just feels
like it's a we didn't want to do that
part
this part's boring
here we go two years from now when it's
exciting again
so
yeah man i uh
i am still i'm still watching them the
night they drop
you know i'm still invested in both of
them i mean i gave whatever it was nine
years of my life to game of thrones at
least i could do this here all right
let's let's see what happens let's see
let's see when we get to the things we
we may or may not know we're going to
get
um i think there's so much more runway
and rings of power that you know i'm not
expecting
you know
the the big isle door
um
elrond fight
against sauron to show up in this show
in the first season maybe that'll be the
finale the finale well there's dovetail
with fellowship in the ring
where is the door refuses to to throw
the ring into the
into the into the pit like that'd be
cool five years that's the end of it
sure i'm down for that
but you know hopefully there's lots more
fun
in the in the interim isn't having fun
i agree i think also
what i love about
rings of power
is every
episode of game of thrones kind of has
that like shock or gotcha moment that
they try to build the episode around
and i like rings of power i actually
like that rings of power doesn't rely on
that it's like here's this thing that
happened the this episode just happens
it feels like
uh a chunk of a
giant story rather than like trying to
you know get you to tune in next week by
dropping
abortion medicine on the counter or
whatever
right
yeah i mean they're they're definitely
advancing story and they're definitely
like turning cards over but it doesn't
seem like it's some
some ploy
by like oh here's this oh this happened
now tune in next week to see what
happens next like well yeah i'm going to
tune in anyway but you don't have to you
don't have to schmuck me
yeah i'm not a schmuck
i'll be here don't worry about that
um but yeah i mean it's it's it's an
interesting time especially in fantasy
tv
um given that we have these two giant
prequels to things that we all know
relatively well if not insanely well
um
you know my my rings knowledge is i read
the hobbit and i read lord of the rings
and i've seen all the words um i've
never read the simarillion i've tried
and failed um numerous times
um the indexes are not a thing that i've
dug into because it also felt very
antiseptic and
i'm always here for character and not
just data
um
so yeah i'm i'm
i guess what do i have my learner's
permit my middle feed and learners
permit in this
for sure it's all one-on-one i'm not
doing advanced studies yet
um but i'm having fun i'm having fun and
that's what it's all about in the kids
just [ __ ] having fun i mean
10 years ago or like remember when x-men
came out and everybody was like oh my
god there's going to be a single
x-men comic movie
and now it's like
well we've got andor dropping on
wednesday night and rings of power
dropping on thursday night and house of
dragon on sunday night she-hulk
somewhere in between it's crazy it's a
crazy time to be alive
yeah yeah there's there's no way you
could have told a nerd
you know 25 years ago that this would be
their lives
you know you could not have told you
know 20 year old me hey buddy
that's what
you're not going to have enough time to
watch all of the [ __ ] they're making
just for you
um
and yeah like i didn't i thought i
hadn't even
realized that andorra was wait wednesday
we get nine
i think it's
uh not this a week from this wednesday
okay thank god
i was not prepared for
to do that work just yet
but the trailer looks great should we
talk about some trailers
talk about the [ __ ] that we saw i
haven't seen a lot of them because uh
i wasn't there but i've seen some of the
stuff that dropped i'll let you lead i'm
gonna disappear
okay i'll pop in if i have anything to
say
yeah outstanding um i however much like
uh jdc was not there i
up there at d23 on friday
um
where it was very game-centric um there
was a couple of animations
dropped but um
saturday seemed to be the mother lode of
the new trailers and new announcements
and all of that stuff
so we talked about the trailers first we
saw a trailer for secret invasion
the uh the nick fury scroll show which
looked um
looked pretty great
you know it's not
and it's it's hard to say
that i i haven't seen a ton of trailers
who look bad i've been looking at things
like
that looks awful
rarely does one stumble upon something
that just looks out not awful
i will say some of the vfx or the early
she-hulk trailers didn't look great but
the trailers themselves were good i mean
they promised story and they promised
character and i think they promised the
show that we the show that we got which
also
the most recent episode was so much fun
i arrived hard
for uh for wonksters and madison
um
yeah holy [ __ ] who who knew
that that was going to be what we were
talking about uh today was uh was
madison but uh
here for it anyway secret invasion looks
great i love the idea of [ __ ] old now
to see nick fury being the guy who's got
to stand between you know
whatever
chaos and order
um apocalypse and salvation
um
pepsi versus coke
um
and he looks great i mean you know the
[ __ ] with the without the ipad just
the clog is yeah i'm all for it i'm all
for
um the sort of espionage stuff that like
falcon winter soldier kind of nudged up
against but never could really
dig into for any number of reasons but
this feels like it's a you know it's
it's the cold war show
um from marvel and so dubbed that very
much
i dug willow way more than i thought i
was gonna dump the trailer because i'm
not that much of a willow guy
you know willow just
missed me
you know maybe there was it was a little
bit too cutesy a little bit too kidsy a
little bit too you know star wars with
actual swords not laser swords
um
you know i mean i saw it when i was
young but it just it never never just
dug into me never sunk its closet um but
the trailer looks kind of great it
reminds me it has a bit of a princess
bride feel to it um it has a bit of a
high adventure feel to it which we don't
get that much any on tv anymore even you
know
in in the rings of power world
that is not it's it's high fantasy but
not high adventure whereas willow feels
like it's high adventure um sword fights
i mean bearing dew and you know
horsebacks and magics and stuff
um
and i kind of i kind of done it um and
it's nice to see warwick davis back man
it's nice to see joanne walling back
it's nice
you know
and and i love that it's just a band of
adventures no nothing adventure [ __ ]
all here for
um
there was a percy jackson in the
olympians teaser that dropped we didn't
get it doesn't show you very much of
much
other than
yeah no totally feels like percy jackson
totally feels you know um it's a little
bit ominous it's a little bit spooky
it's a little bit promising
you know the conflict that's that's
diploma like what if you discover that
you're a half of god
um others how does that ruin your world
is there anything you want to keep quiet
is anything you want to broadcast to
everybody
um i think it's it's it showed you a
little bit but it showed you enough
given that they're still making the show
and i think i don't remember they had a
date on it but it's a while away
um
but i was here for that
um
the little mermaid trail
um
you know i i have been and remain
skeptical of these live action
adaptations of the disney cartoons
um
because most of them feel a bit like
cash grabs um and by most of them i
think the answer is all of them um
that occasionally do manage to take
advantage of the the updating of it to
add something new to the flavor i mean
aladdin
which is very busy and you know the
original cartoon is perfectly fine
but the idea of adding more um agency
for jazz that she actually wanted more
to do you know that she's actually got
her own story as opposed to the like the
one disney princess who's a side car in
her own story um
that's you know that it feels like a
second advantage with the opportunity
and so little mermaid does not show you
much at all all you hear is you know
the the a couple of bars of the most
famous song
um which i don't even know the name of
up there
it feels like it's up there if not
that's one of the other wrestling
um
yes i know i'm about to family uh part
of your world
part of your world there it is thanks
batman for saving me from a multitude of
angry disney fans online
um which are gonna come from anyway but
um
i think that the the
the thing that that i love about it is
that i've been seeing a ton of stuff on
instagram and on tick tock
of just little black girls who get to
see a version of that movie in which
they are the heroine
um
i just think it's it's it is always
powerful and it is always um
necessary
to allow certain people who rarely get
to see themselves as the hero to be the
hero um to be the protagonist to be the
person for whom the movie is about
um
and yes
all of the things that one might want to
say about
um changing what had been previously a
white heroine to a heroine of color
have added
i don't care
i just don't sorry
um
i i
the same arguments that one
people are having about
you know
black valerians and black
um targaryens and black elves and black
harfords and black black people in
anything fantasy um is a is an argument
that i'm exhausted and having to have
but apparently we do this every now and
again
um but fantasy isn't real and fantasy
can be anything
and anybody can be in it and it can be
for everyone so
uh learn from me i may or may not see it
because i don't care that much except i
care that it exists for people for whom
it does mean quite a bit
um
i feel like these next two that we
should talk about we should bring batman
back in because it's andor and the
mandalorian what do you think
jc how did where's where's how does your
deep star wars soul
feel about pandora and the mando
i
am
really excited about andor
uh because i think it's going to look
and feel very very different from every
single thing that we have ever seen star
wars except for maybe rogue one which
if you line everything up that does have
a very different look and feel kind of
tone i mean yes there's tie fighters and
yes darth vader shows up but the way the
story is told is i think very different
but still feels star wars
um andorra is the one i've been looking
forward to the most this whole time
um
i
also am interested because
uh tony gilroy
uh
back when rogue one came out he said i
don't care about star wars but i
understood
these characters in this situation so i
knew how to
make this movie
um and i think it'll be interesting it's
almost like the opposite of jj abrams
who is just like
the only thing we wanted to do with the
force awakens is bring joy
and you're like yeah but you forgot
about plot and characters in a script
um
i i feel like this is almost the
opposite well where gilroy is like i
don't care about the star wars of it i
want to make
an incredibly told story
which is if you think about it what
george did
almost 50 years ago was
he wasn't trying to make a star wars he
was just trying to tell a wonderful
story so i'm i'm very excited about
andor
um i have a question for you it's a
debate that i got into uh while i was at
e23
with uh with a fellow star wars fan
and and the the crux of it is
what makes a star wars star wars to you
um what are the elements that need to be
in a thing in order for it to feel like
star wars to you um for me
that
the things that i need to be in it
are
almost entirely
audio
you know they're they're oral like it's
it's the sounds of those ships it's the
sound of a lightsaber it's a sound of a
droid it's the sound of the score
like that's the stuff that for me
conjures star wars um
and so i get very pavlovian you know
even when you know like
the old 20th century fox fanfare i
always thought star wars followed that
because that was the very first 20th
century foxhound movie i've ever seen
it's like oh it must be star wars movies
it's got the skylights um
and then the the the drum beat
you know it's star wars movies little
did i know that
those two things were not inextricably
intertwined um
but for the person that i that i was
talking to
for him it's
it's the fantasy
you know like for him star wars is about
jedi and and and
magic and the force and
you know that that feeling that it is
not science fiction but it's space
fantasy
and for him the minute you pull the
fantasy out of it you lose the star wars
um
where do you fall
i
think i am more in line with you i think
the thing that yells
star wars to me
and i think it's part of what people my
age and older have such a problem with
the prequels about
is used
used dirty
sci-fi
um
but i think
the biggest thing for me is i want to
feel
uh
familiar in this world
but have it be beyond my
uh imagination right that's like the
scene where you walk into the cantina
we've all walked into a bar we all know
that bar we all watched cheers
but there was something heightened about
it so for me it's it's less the
the force and the jedi and more
i'm
hoping to see
kind of something i haven't seen i'm
hoping for
um
to be transported to something familiar
that is
heightened
i think
so i i'm
excited to not have lightsabers and the
force in a show
because i want to see
the aliens that i think you know one of
the biggest things about a lot of the
star wars that's come out recently is
like
who were the aliens in the
prequel or in the sequel movies it was
like
babu freak and and that one elasti guy
whereas like in the original star wars
like you knew
hammerhead and walrus man and
and
you know all the canteen aliens if i
showed you a picture you're like yes
whereas like i feel like star wars has
fallen away from so much of those
those
other creatures like it's almost like
the galaxy is shrunk as much as people
complain like oh well the skywalkers are
everywhere
um
but
even in the television shows like in
obi-wan and stuff it's like we don't see
the
you know the cantina scene has
80 different aliens in five minutes and
i don't think we got eight different
aliens in seven hours of sequel movies
and i think that
felt weird to me
so i want to see i guess i just want to
be taken to someplace else
that's very familiar but entirely new
i uh i think i side with you on that as
well that that
it's a thing that that star wars
i think has sort of left
by the side of the road
that idea that
there's so much more than just humans in
this galaxy
um you know every now and again you get
you know
a mon calamari you know in in
in mandalorian or you get you know some
kind of creature sitting on a table in
in you know book of boba fett or
whatever
but it's
all of this drama feels like it's human
drama
um and i do miss that this this was at
one point a
a a
a hodgepodge of a galaxy
um and not everything looked kind of the
same that was you know i mean that was
the whole thing with
return of the jedi when they had a
little bit more money was like
oh like the empire are like the nazi bad
guys and so
all the people of different
colors and races and planets all these
people who have been oppressed by this
one
very
singular
like
look
are joining together and that's what
makes them powerful
and i do think that that's lost i hope
we see a ton of
aliens in andor i think that'll be super
cool
yeah i mean i hope so i hope so i my one
fear is that you know because tony
gilroy you know was like i'm not a star
wars guy but i don't know how to tell
the story
i you know i'm hoping he gives a [ __ ]
about that level of of inter-species
interplanetary
um
sort of hodgepodge like just yeah give
me a bunch of different kinds of weird
[ __ ]
you know that's cool
um
mandalorian it looks like more
mandalorian like you they're just giving
you what you love it's like you like
chocolate ice cream you know what we got
this time three scoops do you want a
cherry
we got the cherry
remember that alien you liked from
episode nine he's here
you know
yeah
it felt a bit also like the hey we're
not sure if you watched book of boba
fett so we're going to break down the
mando [ __ ] that you would have gotten
for book of the fit in this trailer
um
and i also wonder if they're just gonna
have to recap that at the top of of
season three if just like hey gang
we know
we know so here's
previously on the mandalorian's last
book of boba fett here's everything that
you missed
um
it i mean it looks fun it looks more
like
i'm i'm all in for it you know they know
how to make they know how to tell us
star wars so i'm there
um i will say the thing that
looks really cool
that's kind of fun is dave filoni
invented a lot of this stuff for a
cartoon
in 2010 or 2009
and he's been able to take that and grow
it into uh
you know live action like the
palace that bogatan is sitting in is you
know straight out of
uh clone wars and i was actually sitting
there watching it thinking
did they
just take did like ilm take the assets
from the clone wars show and just like
res them up and retexture them or did
they reinvent that from scratch and like
that's how close it was
which is also cool because you know if
you got into
star wars
again in 2010
2011 when you were 11 years old
and that's the star wars you grew up
with because every generation has its
own star wars
you're now
22 23 and you're getting to watch
the heroes that you saw in cartoon form
take shape as
as live action which is more suited to
your
you know your sentiment sensibilities at
that age
which i think is kind of a cool thing
like star wars for people of a certain
age
those characters have grown up with them
uh you know ahsoka has grown up with you
if you were her age when you started
watching it
yeah you know and i think also to that
point you know and and we've talked
about in the podcast before that i
during the the pandemic lockdown i made
a good faith effort of trying to get
into clone wars and got you know i i i
scratched more than the surface i
probably watched a good
20 22 episodes
um during that stretch um
but looking at the trailer for tales of
the jedi
um
was like oh
oh this stuff looks awesome like you
know not even knowing deep deep you know
clone wars
saga or arcane raving but like
young count dooku and like how he turns
bad that's [ __ ] rad and no baby
ahsoka that seems cool and mace windu
and and qui-gon as a padawan that's
[ __ ] great like
filling all of that backstory in a
six-episode anthology that's great
i saw that i mean i still like you
mentioning it gave me goosebumps that to
me is
again if i had to pick one thing to
watch like mando season three or and or
or that
i think i'm probably watching that
because that
and it's another thing that like
lucasfilm animation has done so well is
it took the stuff we watched in the
prequels that some of us may or may not
have loved
and it just
it
gives it more definition it gives you it
it helps you understand
what maybe was missing from episode two
or what was missing from episode one and
it kind of like colors that picture in a
little bit better
and makes those movies better
than
what they were
before which i think is pretty cool
yeah like i i do
i do long for and hopefully it'll get
all come to fruition before i die
but the ability to sit down
with all of star wars at once
and like you know what gang
here's how to chronologically watch all
of this [ __ ]
here's here's where the story begins
here's where clone wars comes in here's
where rebels comes in here's where this
episode tells the jedi comes in here's
where mandalorian comes in that you
could watch from beginning to end
you know
or at least up until that particular
date because it'll never end i know this
but you know
maybe just all of this skywalker's up
and everything that has to you know
connect to that
um i think that would be that would be
like a wonderful month to spend
um just swimming it
um
so yeah like it's
it's i was about to say it's a shame
because it's not a shame because it's
it's a choice um but i do it is a thing
that i do want to rectify
which is as a person who grew up you
know suckling at the teat
of star wars to have left so much of it
unwatched um
i'd like to fix that i think you know
uh
there are things towards the end of
clone wars and i've said this a lot and
i guess i'll spoil it but again it's a
show's 10 years old there's a episode
towards the end of clone wars where
uh
you know they kind of do these like it's
like obi-wan and
like
it does what star wars does where it's
like this episode's about r2 and 3po
this episode's about obi-wan and anakin
this episode's about padme and anakin
and there's a set of like two or three
episodes
towards the end
where
uh padme
is tasked with going on a diplomatic
mission with an ex-boyfriend
to a separatist world to try to bring
them back into the republic
and
you know unbeknownst to anybody but
benon to us uh you know anakin and padme
are married at this point
and
he
loses his mind he goes you're not going
to some planet to stay in a hotel room
with your
ex-boyfriend absolutely not we're
married and she's like anakin this is my
job it's for the republic like i'm doing
this and you can't stop me
and there's a very real
relationship
conversation that happens there and the
fast forward she goes anakin shows up
and
goes into their hotel room
and
beats the [ __ ] out of this guy
and in the fight he's like oh you got to
use the force
and towards the end he takes his glove
off and is punching the guy with his
metal hand
in the face on top of him
and then they go to padme and she's just
destroyed and the episode ends with like
i think we need to reevaluate our
relationship
the
end
and so that's this type of character
moments
that the clone wars builds to
that
pay off so much
for the stuff that
you watched in episodes one through six
with anakin and vader and
why is all this happening how did all
this happen
it's it's it's such
it's some of the best
storytelling in chunks that star wars
has ever had
i know
i know
i know i will
i will and no to somebody in chat's like
oh my god is mark dying no i'm not dying
um
i mean yes i'm dying but no more so than
everybody's dying just in
by minute by minute we're all
we're all slouching towards the grave um
but you know it is just
i suppose once you get over the the
middle of the of the journey you start
thinking about the things that one
hasn't done and that there is less time
ahead than there was behind
and so they're like wow what and of
course like last time i had it was
behind what do i want to do with that
um but i'm a nerd and that's what we do
um so yes so we talked andor which i
think is similarly i think looks amazed
um and uh and i am interested in the
star wars stories that are on the
fringes
of the galaxy that do not necessarily
need to involve force users and laser
swords um but still
are about the struggle
you know like it's it's it has always
been about the rebel alliance and the
rebellion and so
tell talk to me about how that was
um
manifested by people who didn't
have the same dad or who couldn't move
mountains with their minds
um
just regular-ass people like doing the
[ __ ] work of
staring down tyranny
um and then punching in the face so yeah
i'm here
was there any rogue squadron
chatter at all
not that i noticed i think that it's
it's one of those the less we're going
to say the better
um you know i think they they mentioned
some acolyte casting but i think that
even broke before d23
um with the squid game guy um
being in it
but yeah i mean rogue squadron seems to
it seems as active as the ryan johnson
star wars church
which you would think somebody's up
there sitting at lucasfilm being like
top gun maverick how what could we do
that's like top gun maverick
if only we had
some sort of space pilot thing that we
could put in star wars that would
generate
the fourth highest grossing movie of all
time in the united states and
billions worldwide if only
if only
yeah that's a bummer
yeah
i mean we i think we pitched it on the
podcast at some point the wedge antilles
started i'm just like you know here's
your [ __ ] x-wing veteran he's just
been leaving squadrons all throughout
the rebel war against the empire
just tell me that big story tell me tell
me tell me the the the witch antilles
last run story
yeah i
uh i feel like there's
a lot of low hanging fruit there
that
people just need to pick up
oh yeah i agree with your friend
um all right so yes what else what are
the trails we get we got werewolf by
night
which uh which looked really interesting
like i don't know what to expect from
werewolf by night um
but it's i mean black and white horrors
all
chamber piece who is the werewolf um
directed by michael chino
um who uh i believe this is his um
filmmaking debut
or two here or there but
it sure looks like fun it looks like a
hammer horror movie it looks like you
know a universal monsters jam
um
and and yeah even though this might be
michael g's
um debut that dude's been around story
for years and some of the best stories
that have ever been made
and so you know the same way that actors
can become
great directors
by uh absorbing by being on set by
listening by taking advantage of the
access to directors and filmmakers and
learning while on the job
no reason to think that a composer could
do the same
because they're also working very close
proximity to filmmakers and directors
and writers and being privy to various
versions of
the movies that they work on that if
you're if you're the person who learns
that way and learns by osmosis then that
person can come from anywhere
also i mean they're telling
characters story and plot through music
especially in
the type of movies
jakino
scores
um
you know not to take anything away from
like a trent reznor
but a lot of his stuff is mood
where i feel like john williams shaquino
uh
han zimmer hans zimmer like they can
tell story through
music like you can almost listen to and
one of my friends has a podcast called
the soundtrack show and if you look at
the notes
of the star wars main theme
and you look at the plot points of
joseph campbell's hero's journey they
overlay on top of each other
so
i mean it is
if anybody can do it he can do it
yeah and so i'm super excited to see
what that ultimately looks like because
yeah give me more give me more marble
horror marvel horror
um here for it um and i think the last
trailer that i saw that dropped
that i thought was with our team t
mentioned was moon girl and devil
dinosaur which i was a comic that i
never read
but always knew that it existed um
but it looks like
[ __ ] candy-colored joy
i mean you know this this girl who
managed to open a dimensional rift and
summons a dinosaur who's a double
dinosaur and they bought to fight crime
and
she's got you know the [ __ ] giant
poofs the power poofs
you know she looks like a disney
princess um who also wears goggles and
fights crime with a giant dinosaur um
so i'm here for that
um let's see okay newswise we're just
gonna go
down the [ __ ] roster of just the [ __ ]
that they announced live action film
um live-action television you know the
animated stuff all of it that kind of
vectors into our spheres of interest
marvel um showed off a little bit of new
footage from quantum mania um which
opens next february uh similarly they
showed off some new footage from wakanda
forever
um
you know apparently you know
more queen ramonda stuff
um
captain america new world order
announced that tim blake nelson is
returning as the leader
and and shir haas is also joining the
cast which is in uh about 18 months from
now may 3rd 2024.
um kevin feige confirmed what had been
rumored for a couple of weeks that matt
shachman is going to be taking over for
john watts as director of the fantastic
four
um and that movie's coming out november
8th in 2024
um
they rolled out the cast of the
thunderbolts or at least some of the
caster bulbs um which include david
harbor uh julian mcdrivers wyatt russell
florence pugh sebastian stan and john
cayman and olga kirilenko so that's
um
yeah that's all the computer characters
from black widow and we're getting you
know white russell back as the us agent
and we're getting florence pew back as
as elena and sebastian stan you know um
that fella seems like he's the star of a
tv show um and or the center of a movie
um ghost
hannah hannah and john came in from from
ant-man 2
um and taskmaster so yeah man here for
that one i am so frustrated
that they have yet to release on the
internets the trailer for indiana jones
five
it it hurts so much that i haven't seen
that yet
but uh
but i can't wait i mean
for all for all the reasons but i you
know i'm i'm i'm a one last riot kind of
person like i love
i love the final the final stories of
heroes the sunset sunset journeys
um
and harrison ford did reveal
that uh this will be his last time
playing indiana jones
uh i'm done he said i will not fall down
for you again
did um
did you see the inter the picture that
made the entirety of the internet cry
it was
so pure it's the happiest i've ever seen
in harrison ford
yeah
yeah you know it's and i'm sure that you
have seen it at home um on various and
sundry instagram feeds and and all over
the internet but it was harrison ford
and keaton quan um just hugging each
other and like there's this beaming grin
of just
i don't know status sharing harrison
ford's face like that dude has seemed
readily grumpy for like 20 years but he
just just beaming like a school boy it
was just so lovely
did um
we talked about it i think on this show
uh
a year ago or two years ago when he came
back to acting
i was like
is it a coincidence that he came back
right at the time that indiana jones
five started filming
and he was there for
loki right he wasn't there for indy
he has to have been
in indy like they know what they're
doing and if he wasn't in indy after the
reaction to that photo getting posted
how do you not go back and reshoot
something
yeah just one scene just give me the one
scene where he's gonna go back to you
know shanghai for some reason or another
he he's like afraid to go back because
of the way he left things with short
round or whatever the [ __ ] it is just
you just need one seat
short round
short round owns club obi-wan
and he's like i bought this bar
because this is where it all started
going wrong with you
give me that whole movie
yeah just do it just do it midnight run
but with absolutely
did you see the um
there's an image floating around a week
or two ago of a
harrison ford
now in the indie thing and somebody had
de-aged him
the same photo side by side
i hope they do some of that like i hope
we get some of that sweet robert downey
jr like bring 80 year old harrison back
to like 50
and uh and get get some of that
yeah i mean
there's there's no reason you can't and
i think i saw somebody that the budget
was like 200 million dollars or 250
million dollars for this movie which is
an insane amount of money for a raiders
film
unless you're spending a decent chunk of
that money
harrison
so this story can take place over
multiple time zones um
so yeah no i i can't believe i can't or
like if it's
you know so if what indiana jones was
say
40 in last crusade-ish
yeah and that takes place in like 1944
so this movie would be taking place in
1984
so is it a cold war
movie
and do you get
do you give us just like a 10 minute
opening montage
of harrison of d aged harrison from
ninth from last crusade until where this
one starts
or i guess i guess it would have to be
crystal skull right i forget that movie
exists
i feel like we can both just pave right
over crystal skull and nobody would mind
but how awesome like almost like um
that terrible wolverine movie
that they did x-men origins you know how
that opens with wolverine and sabretooth
through the ages like i would sit
through a john williams scored
10 minute
the best of indiana jones over the past
35 years montage
all day long
in fact i'd probably
watch it every morning instead of
drinking coffee to get me ready for my
day
if they did that so
you know you're like the smithsonian or
whatever the museum of natural history
and it's some
you know awards ceremony for indiana
jones where they're giving him whatever
the the the archaeologist equivalent of
an oscar is
and it's it's that scene in a in
chaplain right the ending of chaplain
where like if you've never seen chaplin
it's a it's a vlog movie but the finale
that i always loved which is robert
downey jr charlie chaplin is not sure
that americans remember who the hell he
is and they convinced him to come back
from paris to america for an honorary
oscar
and up until the very moment of that
night he's on the fence i should just go
back they're not going to give a [ __ ]
like an old man i never did anything
good
and then they do this bit where he's
backstage as they're playing the film
montage of all of charlie chaplin's
stuff and he's just watching
as the audience is laughing and
responding to all of the stuff that
we've sort of seen over the course of
that of the movie you know
the stuff that we saw in filming but now
the black and white version of it
and it's
it's that story of a man who doesn't
realize the impact that he's had on the
world
and so what has indiana jones done
for the the the fate of humanity like
how has he
impacted the world as we know it and to
to have that character confronted with
the work that he's done for good and for
ill would be a lovely sort of moment and
then you can do the like indy through
the ages and here he is at you know 50
and 45 and 60 and here he is shaking
hands with presidents and here he is
you know knocking on the door so we can
see where they put the ark and like all
of that stuff like just the the greatest
hits of indiana jones before this the
last adventure like that's that would be
fun it would also just tie in like you
think like
last crusade
he's in a classroom like it would fall
into that like the adventure doesn't
start until after
like donovan's
apartment in san francisco like it would
just oh
now i'm going to be disappointed
yeah we won't get it and it'll be fine
um
let's see what else is the 20th century
and i showed some more footage from
avatar way of the water the way of water
um
i guess apparently it was cool
and 3d and underwater um so great um
disney live action announced uh the
title of the lion king prequel that
barry jenkins is directing it's called
mufasa the lion king
which will be out in 2024
let's see there were a bunch of animated
things that that sort of pixar and
disney announced um elemental
which is coming next june from pixar um
leo
another pixar movie in 2024
let's see what their synopsis is but
eleven-year-old dreamer elio uh will
also feature america ferrara adrian
molina is the director
um elio is artistic creative and an avid
endorsement he finds it hard to fit in
meanwhile mom oliver who runs the top
secret military project
is working through the code of strange
signal from outer space but it's leo who
makes contact gets beamed into space
that is subsequently mistaken for
intergalactic ambassador um that's cute
enough
um amy poehler is coming back for inside
out two from pixar
um
let's see television tv tv tv marvel i'm
sure a little bit of iron heart um
which does you know i can't say whether
it looked great or not
um
but uh but ryan coogler is definitely on
board as an executive producer in that
show so
i definitely think he has feels about
making sure that that's right we talked
about secret invasion um armor wars with
don chill reprising his role as colonel
james rhodes
um
they i don't know if they've even
started shooting that yet they might
have but they haven't given a date for
the premiere
um
loki season two we just talked about uh
ki hui kwang uh is joining the cast
um which tom hiddleston and juan wilson
and sophia demartino are all returning
um and they're shooting that now
um echo is coming um
with uh luck with cox and vincent
d'onofrio and every jacobs and graham
green cody lighting and a bunch of other
people um that certainly the premiere
date is not yet announced
daredevil born again
um of course we knew that was coming we
knew that i think it was like 18
episodes of the first season
um which you know [ __ ] yeah give me more
daredevil give me lots more daredevil um
talk about one little financial with
gaia gail garcia bernal and laura
donnelly
um
it's their first standalone tv special
and it'll be on october 7th um
and already talked about mandalorian we
talked about
uh star wars bad batch um premiere of
season two has been pushed in september
28th on january 4th tell us the jedi we
talked about whoo
um
ezra bridger is officially headed to
ahsoka with uh
iman is
playing
that character
[Music]
see there's a trailer for american-born
chinese
um based on the jin yang
graphic novel which looked super [ __ ]
cool
um
what else we got muppets mayhem national
treasure
edge of history to trailer for that show
picking up that story about finding
clues and [ __ ]
um
yeah star wars young jedi adventures
um
which is uh lucasfilm sort of kid super
kid disney junior thing that will appear
on this nature unit 2023
that is all of the news that uh that i
spotted coming out of d23
um
you know not a ton of depth because
that's not what d23 is about it's about
shock and awe so look at all of these
people look at how pretty they are look
at them all standing on the stage
excited to be in whatever they're in
um
excuse me i miss the trailers
that honestly we're excited about and
i didn't really see a bad one
um of the stuff that they released you
know i mean and again of the stuff that
they released we talked about that
there's a trailer out there that will
probably be dropped
uh in front of some
um marvel and or uh disney related movie
um this coming fall winter whatever had
to guess maybe in front of avatar
um
and uh and avatar stuff that we haven't
that that second trailer i'm still
waiting to see more of but [ __ ] it man
it is like we just talked for an hour
about all the [ __ ] they announced at d23
and that's just
disney that is just marvel star wars and
pixar and animation there's there's
whole other segments of the nerd sphere
that hasn't told us what they're doing
again and holy [ __ ] man cannot wait
cannot wait
um
and so that is the end of the news part
of our program and as much as there's
one more thing
another thing that i saw another new d23
typically know
is that uh is that there's gonna be a
podcast let me see if i still have this
story on my yes
um because i just i loved this idea so
[ __ ] much
um
there's going to be a podcast
about
um
what happened to khan noonian singh
while he was on city alpha
um
we've never
found out what that story was what was
the the was supposed to be a promised
land turned into a nightmare um the
reason why kirk uh execs want some
executive advantage i'm sorry why can't
what's exactly right john kirk
what how did that was supposed to be the
the colony of paradise devolve into a
nightmare um it's not going to be a
podcast 40 years after wrath of khan
nicholas meyer the police writer
director is returning to tell that story
in star trek's first scripted podcast um
something they announced on star trek
day
and
you know [ __ ] hate it i'm i can't
wait i i don't even know why i can't
wait so much but i can't um
that was the other bit of news that i
spotted that i wanted to share
because it just i uh
it made me happy
and made me happy
um
but that's it that's all the news we
have today boys and girls um
jc do we have anybody who wants to
answer and have some questions answered
or do we all just want to just go home
i've got a couple questions uh one of
them
uh six stowe in twitch chat
wanted to know if you saw the trailer
for warrior queen
warrior queen
i don't think i did
what's warrior queen on
i don't know
let's look it up
we'll google it
[Music]
i mean
near as i can tell
there's
looks like you're queen
1987. yeah that's all i'm getting too
uh well i mean there's the woman king
which uh which i honestly cannot wait
for the the gina prince blythewood movie
with viola davis
um
and moses ingram oh the woman king yes
sorry
looks like autocorrect attack of
autocorrect
um yeah that i can't wait for um
which is apparently the true story of
this elite fighting force
that uh
that as legend has it
part of the the the amazon myth
was based upon these these female
warriors from
from dahomey i believe is the uh is the
name of the the city state from whence
they come
but uh no i can't [ __ ] wait that's i
think this friday the movie comes out i
know it premiered up in toronto we've
been talking to international film
festival this past week and and it's
rolling out this weekend and i can't
wait i will probably watch viola do this
smash people on the head with axes
all day long
um
and then i had a question from hyper hex
says since you enjoy story games
yourself would there be any other comic
book adaptation of a video game you
would want to bring to a council who
would it be
um
a comic adaptation of a video game so
taking a game and then making a comic
book out of it
um i i think the opposite i think taking
a certain comic book and making it
um
i mean i know they've they've tried it
before i don't know how successful they
were
um i think i wanted i tried to play one
once and it just didn't engage me
but i still think
there's a great open world cone of the
barbarian game to be made um i think
there's lots of great conan the
barbarian stories to be told um but that
feeling of like yeah no you've gotta
you've got a ready-made world you've got
you know nations and governments and
and you know rulers and and various you
know magics and all of it like
i don't know it seems kind of ripe for
some kind of
you know third person witcher style game
about uh conan the sumerian as he leads
the frosted north to
trample the jeweled thrones under his
sandal feet um
that'd be great to be fun
somebody let me do that
okay
i'm putting it into the world
like like similarly you put i want to be
chung cheese in the world i'm gonna do a
conan barbarian video game um
yes render under caesar what is his
sure
bamf uh one other question
and i didn't
copy the person's name so i apologize uh
charlie cox told us the new daredevil
show is a reboot
uh if mark could reboot any marvel dc or
sci-fi what would it be and why kind of
sounds like kona and the barbarian but
um
yeah but i think you know i'll stick
specifically to marvel
um
but you know i
i wanted so badly
because there's a thing i grew up in the
70s and the 80s born in the 70s grew up
in the late 70s and the 80s like as a
person who was engaged with the world
um didn't have until then which was the
height of like bruce lee movies and kung
fu theater on saturdays on on new york
local stations and
finding you know ways to to like is
there a sheldon temple anywhere near me
in the bronx no um okay i guess i can't
become michelle and monk
that was my very first career plan
um but i had such high hopes as that
kind of person for uh for iron fist and
uh did not go well
and did not uh did not turn out to be a
thing that um
that i enjoyed
very much
i do think it's a missed opportunity um
i think there's lots of ways you could
do it
um as we talked about in the pockets at
the time i think there's there's 100
version of it where he's he's biracial
and he's being
tugged between two worlds
you don't necessarily want to repeat
chongqi
um but at the very least you could have
made a show that actually had some
decent martial arts in it and that was
not the one that did
so i think there's i think there's
there's potential for that i think
i mean
[ __ ] powerman and iron fist
should have been great
um
and was only so so and that's mostly
because powerman was doing all the heavy
lifting which he should because he's
stronger but still
um
i think there's there's probably a
version of that story of those
characters
that could work in a in a modern
part in a good way
so yes that's that's the one i tried
i tried for that and if i couldn't do
that i want to do mega force
dudes in dune buggies and and
motorcycles and dirt bikes um
fighting terrorism on the international
scale by being dropped out of planes so
they can drive the duke buggy center
bikes
over to
conquer the badness that spreads
throughout the world deeds not words
boys and girls give me that [ __ ] mega
force
um
yeah
what about you know what could be fun
because
they're about done and you're not you're
going to have within like five or six
years
you'll have a bunch of people who've n
who don't know kiss is a band
could you turn kiss
into
like an actual dramatic
superhero team
kind of like in a almost like uh
like uh
suicide squad type where where they're
like bad guys doing good
yeah there's there's totally like the
hellboy version of kiss right where
they're like
they're they're demons who are who are
who are sensed to fight demons
you know and it's it's for them to guard
the gates between worlds and it turns
out that the best way to keep between
worlds closed
is by rock and roll but sometimes
you actually need to punch a demon in
the throat and so yeah like there's
there's some there's some kind of like
oka banzai meets hellboy version
which uh
uh
you know i bet you you could pitch that
movie that story that that tv show to
gene simmons and you'd be like you know
what
all right i'll let you run with it he's
six months six months you've got the
soundtrack
i mean it's all there
it's
50 years of
music
uh he would be finding a way to not have
kiss be in it
well i mean
they're 80 i feel like i mean they're
gonna they got to be hanging it up the
same way harrison is
pretty much but yeah there's there's
probably some kind of
like rocket man meets hellboy
version of kiss
prince cast a bunch of young people you
see that they're also rock stars who
while being rock stars also
kept this plane of existence safe yeah
um um fred like i'd like to watch that
like make it good like it's not like
winking at the camera like you're just
like no this is going to be good no the
reality we're living in we're invested
in this is truth
um freddie lane you mentioned this a
little bit uh
are you able to share any details on how
you were approached to do the new marvel
game
congratulations to big fan of your work
yeah thank you um the the the approach
was relatively simple
um
inasmuch as
um amy henning um she the creative
director beyond behind this game and the
uncharted games
um
and a in a star wars game that sadly
won't ever see the light of day although
she's working on the star wars game but
anyway um
uh she's she has for a long time been
writing
um in a partnership with a fellow named
todd stashwick who is a friend of mine
as has previously established also a
co-host uh previous governor's the black
man beyond me um
he is he was working on this game before
i was and when they got to the phase
where they wanted to like bring in some
writers and start working on breaking
story and assembling a writer's room um
he reached out to me to ask if i was
interested and then i got the like
secret non-disclosure agreement stuff
from sky dance who couldn't really tell
me what anything was but like i know
todd and todd's smart and so i trusted
him enough to you know get on the zoom
and see what people are talking about
and i have heard of skydance clearly um
and so you know once we got on the zoom
and once we vetted all of the nda stuff
and
promised me not to tell anybody anything
or i promised them that i wouldn't tell
anybody anything for years um then they
told me what the game was and then i was
like oh well [ __ ] yeah duh don't want to
write a black panther captain america
game i would very much like to be a
captain american game um
so that was it and then there was some
negotiations there's deal making but it
didn't take very long because it's a job
that i wanted to do
um
there are there are negotiations that
take longer
because either a i am not that excited
but you know we'll do it or
the the company i'm negotiating with are
morons
but this would
everybody wanted to make it happen so it
happened pretty quickly
um
and the process is still ongoing
excuse me we spent like i said you know
good
year
most of that pandemic uh lockdown
um i was in zooms you know two three
times a week um with this team just
breaking the story and and and cranking
through it and figuring out the
character moves and the turns and the
reversals and fought and carried all of
that stuff
um
and we broke it a little bit like it's a
tv show it's going to be a bingeable
experience it is not
it was not designed to be some 90
hours of gameplay
um but it was designed to be a
incredibly investing um sort of short
push and by short push i mean it's like
a tv show you know like
eight hours ten hours of a tv show
except you get to play it
um
so yes that's how i got on board that's
how i that's how i ended up in
um occupy paris slash wakanda
i hope that clarifies
anything
i
hope i didn't say anything i shouldn't
have said
i might have
probably not though i'm getting good at
this
um
uh one last question
from zero zaku one
uh which
i don't think there's really a right
answer to this but uh he's uh or they
say
what is the order of operations for
people who want to write for a living
the order of operations from being from
going from being an amateur writer to a
professional
because professional
uh just means you're getting paid for it
um that is that is all you have to do to
be a professional you can always still
be a writer but you want to be
professional writing got to get someone
to give you money um now it depends on
what kind of writing you want to do
um i believe you did say television or
film and we'll pretend that that's the
thing
um is writing novels and comic books and
podcasts and being a journalist those
are all different
trees as
routes for you to go from amateur to
professional
but
um
it's it's it's
i would be lying if i said that it
wasn't almost impossible because it is
the numbers proved that out um
there are some
probably four to five thousand people
right now actively working
in hollywood on television shows or
movies um and getting paid to do it um
and that's probably about as many people
out there who also play professional
sports um
there are maybe
you know
i don't know
3 000 baseball players maybe
um 2000 basketball players you know 3
000 football players
baseball and basketball are much less
baseball has i think like 730
active
major league baseball players at any
time and then yeah maybe 2000 when you
hit minor leagues
same with basketball football much more
because there's three times the number
of people on a team but still
probably less than 10 000 total on all
of those things
right so so there's less professional
writers there are there are professional
athletes
um and the odds are just as long
um
because everybody
to one degree or another believes that
they can write because everybody has
written
you know everybody doesn't think they
can be an actor everybody doesn't think
they can be a director or a painter or a
musician because those things um
feel like they are a skill
unapproachable but writing is a thing
we've all written emails we've all
written letters we've all written you
know whatever and so the act of writing
does not seem alien so people think they
can do it the biggest barrier is that
most people don't finish what they start
um
it's impossible to get better at this if
you don't
finish if you don't iterate if you don't
start and finish a thing rewrite it and
then write something else and then with
each thing that you write you should
hopefully be getting better
at the job and again it's
to a certain degree that doesn't matter
what you're writing be it a novel or a
comic book or a stage play or a radio
show
um
the more you do it the better to get at
it um
i i would say today the the paths of of
getting paid to write
um require getting an agent most likely
um you could submit to festivals or
contests there's only a couple of them
that actually matter
um most
most ways online where people will
charge you money for entering some
screenplay festival here or some
you know
i will read your script and give you
notes and give you coverage they call it
and help make you better is all nonsense
um
you know they're they're they're either
being run by
by people who are being disingenuous or
people who have never done it and uh
because if they could do it they
wouldn't be doing this
um
the only real way to do it is to keep
doing it is to keep writing and and
hopefully get better as you go um
find a group of people that are that are
your contemporaries hopefully they live
where you live and if not you can stay
in contact with them and form a bit of a
of a writer's group
and share your work with other people
and get those notes back and and and
start to to rewrite based on some of the
notes that you agree with and to
understand
um
and
make a thing
you know i mean it used to require you
like being in los angeles and going on a
bunch of general meetings and networking
at
at parties and nightclubs and bars or
whatever and
and you know finding
the right time to show up at a record
store where you knew that some executive
would be there and
strike up a conversation and do all that
awful [ __ ] um to get somebody to agree
to read your work um
but now you can make a thing like you
can make a short film and put it up on
the internet you can spread the word
and hope it goes viral um
you know
making a thing has gotten easier and
easier as the technology in our pockets
becomes better and better
you now have a a movie studio and a
distribution arm within your phone and
so
you know it's it's hard for people who
want to sit down and read you know
they'll only ever give you 10 pages
worth of their time and if it's not
great in 10 pages they won't read
anymore but they'll watch five minutes
of it short if it's funny if it's scary
if it's interesting
um so make a thing and hope it hope it
gets it out there hope it spreads
but it's always going to be hard and the
shots are always going to be long
because there's you know a million
people who want to do it and only 5 000
to get to um
and those are numbers you need to find a
way to make peace with because it is
very much reaching for the brass ring
and
i mean i i got lucky
and i think everybody who does this for
a living will tell you that there's some
version of luck that's involved
but it's also
positioning yourself as best you can and
then my path was different from
everybody else's because i was a
journalist first
and from journalism i got to write
comics and from comics i got an agent
then for me from that i got another
agent who then eventually got me a job
um and then journalism would put me into
contact with you know other people in
the business other writers other
producers you know directors it helped
it helped me to form that base that
network that at some point decided that
they wanted to see if they could help
um
as kevin says find a way to surround
yourself by people who want to say yes
and don't say no
and so
i don't know how much more advice i can
give on going from amateur to
professional other than doing the work
and making it as good as you can and
then trying to position yourself in such
a way that you can share that work with
other people and hopefully at some point
somebody will want to give you money to
write a thing um
but every person's journey is different
mine will be different than yours will
be different from his that'll be
different from hers will be different
from theirs
um
all you can do is write
like that's that's the magic bullet is
you know you can write your way out and
if you're good
and if you can be great then you've got
a shot but that shot's always going to
be long
i hope i didn't
crush any dreams but
but it's it's a hard road
i'll uh i'll throw out there it's not
my story but it's a good friend of
mine's
story
on her path to becoming a
professional writer meaning that's what
she does to pay her bills and that was
um
i met uh
a woman named amy ratcliffe
uh who i had seen talking about star
wars stuff on twitter at the hollywood
bowl for a star wars
musical concert one night
uh and she and i became friends because
it was star wars and it was like 2008
and she worked for a like a dog food
company she like did
whatever logistics or whatever for a dog
food company and she's like yeah but i'm
i'm gonna be a writer and she started a
blog
and blogged and blogged and blogged and
then somebody was like hey do you want
to
be a host and talk about star wars on a
podcast and then it was
hey i see your writing do you want to
volunteer writing for like starwars.com
and it was like every year she got like
one more outlet that was willing to give
her one or two or maybe three stories
and she always did them and she always
got them done and she always did her day
job and then one day
in like
2014 or so she was like hey i'm quitting
my
dog food job i think i can i'm making
enough freelance writing that i don't
need my day job anymore
and then
she got asked she did one of those uh
star wars
uh certain point of view
which was some of the first
um
fiction that she wrote she wrote a star
wars kids book
and um
i believe now she's like
one of the top three people at nerdist
like manager managing editor at nerdist
um so you know she is somebody who gets
paid to write who gets paid to write
about what she loves
and you know she's not writing a marvel
movie but like you know she wrote uh
a book about the mindfulness of being a
jedi like she's doing really really cool
stuff and making a good living
doing
what she loves and talking about what
she loves so
i mean it is somebody you know if you're
like the only way that i will be happy
is if i'm writing a movie that a hundred
million people see
you know
at the risk of sounding like kevin like
adjust your expectations you know it's
your goal to be
a great actor or is your goal to be
famous if your goal is to make money
writing stories
that people will
see and enjoy and maybe you change
somebody from in that way
you don't need to
write a marvel television show to do
that you can write
you know a children's book that people
like me write read to their daughters
growing up that's going to change
the way that i relate to my daughter
because she loves the book and i love
star wars and and it's one of
three different star wars children's
books out there so i think part of it is
just looking at what's the actual goal
versus
what's the
dream goal you know what's the
what counts like what counts for being a
professional writer and if it's like i
want to
change people's lives with my words
that's a lot
different than being i want to be one of
the
600 people who gets a chance to
write star wars or marvel
you know
yeah
yeah you know if
it is as as jc said you know what is
what is the truth of it
um what do you want to be doing um
and writing as i said at the very job
takes lots of different forms what form
do you want to chase
um and there's parents
that all require a certain amount of
just dedication to it and resilience
there's going to be a lot more rejection
and there is acceptance and you have to
be okay with that um
and you have to do the work
because it's not going to come easy
um
and for those that it does come easy it
doesn't last
so
put in your reps
get uh get strong and get good um and
then then start doing the best work that
you can and and knock on wood try to get
it into the hands of people who can
maybe help
because it is going to take a village um
so find find your tribe and then get to
work
i hope that helps i hope that that at
the very least
um adds some level of reality to it but
also a little bit of actionable
information
um but yeah at its core
writers write
and uh and writers finish because if
you're not finished then you can't move
on to the next thing you won't learn
anything unless you you you make it done
done is the engine of more so start
writing stuff and finishing them and
then keep going until it breaks
and then uh if
it is entirely possible to write things
that nobody but you reads and still be
happy about being a writer
um you're not a professional but maybe
that's not the reason why you're writing
um
because
most of the writers that i know
they write because they can't do
anything else that's the only thing that
makes them happy even if they're
miserable
and many of them are
um
so yeah good luck
good luck i hope
i hope you find some success help you
find a path to professionalism
um and i hope i get to read some stuff
of yours at some point someday
um
there you go
um i think
that is an episode black man beyond you
guys um thank you for riding along with
me on this my uh
my getting my feet wet back in the solo
podcast arena um
next week i will not be by myself
um i'm debating whether or not i should
say
who my guest will be next week it'll be
next tuesday um
we're doing a bit early because he's
leaving
to go on his press tour for his giant
movie that he's going to be in
i think that movie's out in
october um but uh but he is kindly going
to break off
a little bit of time to chat with me
about nerd [ __ ]
about the movie that he's in
about his path and his process
um
and and how he got to be
the uh
the herald of the age of the geek
um
uh
i'm gonna pop in next week is a virtual
show and we've talked for almost two
hours and forgot to mention
tickets are on sale right now
for a live
black man beyond it scum and villainy
october 11th
and uh
who was it trash panda i think in chat
asked
uh is your guest going to be malcolm not
next week
but
on october 11th
malcolm is back
indeed
i'll give his man
we uh i i cannot wait to let loose
whatever stream of insanity is going to
follow
when malcolm gets behind the ball with
me but it's gonna be so much
um
but yes
malcolm's in the house on the 11th and
yes tickets are on sale go ahead and buy
them also on sale tomorrow if you guys
are our comixology shoppers and fan tv
digital comic books um
the first issue of a new comic book that
i co-wrote called census
drops tomorrow uh co-wrote it with my
buddy adam freeman art by sebastian it
is
um
and it's a it's a bit of a hard comedy
book um i it's all on my socials i've
been talking about it all day i want to
talk about too much i'll talk about it
next week too um but for now
um black man beyond tickets are on sale
now for october 11th me and malcolm
barrett behind the bar cracking wise
making jokes drinking drinks um next
week special mystery guest um once uh we
narrowed down the time i will share who
that is as well um but as always thank
you
um for being with me on on
the the careless
uh initiative that is black man beyond
um we will uh we'll be back next week um
same black time same black channel
um
smilecast.com or youtube.com
kevin smith
good night
be well
clean click
um
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the
aka ask of anything every saga has a 10
year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith
[Music]